How's everybody doing? I'm Dalton. I'm a
partner at Y Cominator. Um, in addition,
I'm the head of admissions, um, which is
our selection process for the companies
that get into YC. I am here to talk
about pivoting. Um,
yeah, let's talk all about pivoting.
Cool. All right. Here's some stuff.
We're going to cover what the heck is a
pivot, why you should pivot, when you
should pivot, and evaluating ideas to
pivot to. So, we're going to try to
cover all the bases here. All right.
Let's talk about the term pivot. Um,
this is one of those terms that if I'm
in a cafe and I hear someone talking
about pivoting, I roll my eyes because
it's one of those words uh that I
associate with annoying startup people.
Um, and so let's let's just uh explain
what we mean here. It just means
changing your idea. That's all it means.
And technically, if we want to be really
technical, I would call a true pivot
where it's like a real company and you
have lots of users and you've raised
money and you're like, we're going to
shut this thing down and do something
different. So, the most famous example
is Slack. Um, they raised money and had
like 100 employees for this video game
um called Glitch. I was a beta user and
they went just shut it down and like did
something crazy. I would call that a
pivot. I think that's a valid use of it.
probably what most of the folks here are
doing. I interchangeably call it
pivoting, but you should just call it
changing your idea. Um, it should feel
really lightweight when you're at the
earliest stages of your company,
especially pre-launch or very near after
launch. Changing your ideas constantly
is kind of the the norm. And I wouldn't
think that this is some huge thing. It
should feel lightweight. And frankly, if
you're not in a state where you're
rapidly changing ideas or assumptions
over and over and over again in quick
succession, you are likely doing it
wrong. You are likely moving too slow.
And so, this is just like part of it.
Changing your idea constantly. Um,
trying to find exactly the right version
of your idea is something you should be
doing in the beginning. Let's talk about
why you should pivot. So, the main
reason I would argue is opportunity
cost. And the definition of opportunity
cost is that uh the loss of potential
gain from other alternatives where one
alternative is chosen. So in other
words, you can only really work on one
thing at a time. Sometimes people try to
violate that rule, but that's a whole
different topic. Um and so by working on
something that's not working and you
have evidence that it's not working, you
are taking opportunity cost to not be
doing something else. It's as simple as
that, right? I don't know. I tried to to
write some pseudo code here for you
about a you know, it's a kind of a joke.
Um, but like how well things are working
divided by the number of months of
concerted full-time effort. If that
number is less than excitement to work
on something else plus confidence you
can find something better, you should
pivot. And so the key thing to if you
like look at this equation like what am
I really trying to say? It's that if
you've worked on something for months
and months and months and months and
it's not happening, like that's a pretty
good signal, right? Like that's what
drives this equation that I put here the
most is the number of months you worked
on something and it's not working. Um,
and so if you're throwing good good
money after bad, good time after bad,
and it's not happening for you, that is
a pretty darn good signal. But if it's
really, really, really early, and you've
only been working on something a couple
of weeks, it's less obvious. Let's give
you some good reasons to pivot. I hate
working on it. All right. Um, it's not
growing. It's just not working. I'm keep
doing the thing and nothing is
happening. I'm not a good fit to be
working on this idea. like the more you
learn about this, the more you realize
that you are just not the right person
for the idea. Um, another one is I'm
relying on an external factor outside of
my control to make my startup take off.
So, a couple of examples of that are
like relying on mainstream virtual
reality headset adoption. That's a good
one. You know, like any day now the new
Facebook uh thing is going to take off
and and you know, that's when my VR
app's going to take off. Um, or like
relying on like mainstream crypto
adoption, things like that. Um, those
are like totally out of your control.
And if you're just sitting here hoping
someone else does something good and
then your startup will work, man, you
should definitely pivot. Another one is
just where you're out of ideas on how to
make the thing work. You're just you've
thrown everything against the wall to
make your current idea work and you're
you're actually kind of out of ideas.
That's usually a sign you should pivot.
Good reasons to not pivot, um, you're
trying to run away from doing hard work.
Sometimes you see people where they
build a product and right when it gets
to sales time they pivot and they do
that over and over again. That's
probably not a good reason to pivot.
It's just someone trying to dodge the
sales part. Um so watch out for that. Um
also another reason not to pivot is if
you're you're the type of person that
changes their idea over and over and
over and over again like chronically um
and you're detecting yourself doing
that. It's good to actually follow
something through all the way. So you
just want to watch out for that
happening. Also, um, a good reason not
to pivot is that like, you know, you
just hear there's some hot new thing and
you want to pivot because you read a
techrunch article because someone raised
money for a hot new thing. That's not a
great reason to pivot. Let me give you
some reasons on why people take too long
to pivot. And the reason I mention this
is I would argue on average most people
take too long to pivot, right? I think
that's usually like if I had to put
people in buckets, more people take too
long than uh than the reverse. And so
why do they take too long? Loss
aversion. when you feel like you've
invested in something, you have a really
hard time letting go to it. And that's
loss aversion. You can you can research
this. Um have a little bit of traction,
like you have a few users or like one
customer, you're like maybe it'll work.
That will make you not pivot. Um and
that's that's rough. Um another thing is
like people are very polite in the world
and they have a hard time telling you
the truth that they don't like the thing
that you're working on. Um and so a lot
of founders get confused about
politeness
um and getting that confused with
traction. And so you're never gonna
really I mean maybe I shouldn't say
never most likely you're not gonna have
people being like your idea is horrible
give up now I will never be a customer.
They're not going to tell you that to
your face. They're going be like oh this
is great. Maybe if you add a few more
features and come back you know we'll
take a look at it. Right? Oh that's
dangerous. [laughter] Um because you can
end up doing that iteratively over and
over and over again for like years and
never actually get customers. So watch
out for politeness and getting
politeness confused with traction.
Another one is fear of admitting
weakness or defeat. If you pivot, you're
giving up in some way. Um, another one
is putting blame on why things aren't
working on um customers or investors.
So, this is where you're like, I'm not
wrong. The world is wrong. You know,
like no one gets this. This is like way
ahead of its time. Um, things like that
are not a not a great sign. Um, and
usually people realize that maybe it is
kind of on them versus on the external
world, but it takes a long time to get
there. And then finally, there's a lot
of inspirational stuff out there that's
just like if you just believe hard
enough and keep going, you know, the
you'll eventually be recognized and
everything will be great. Um, and so
there's a lot of those inspirational
messages out there and that can kind of
be counterproductive. I don't know this
is super legible, but basically this is
where I talk about the little bit of
traction thing. I call it the uncanny
valley of product market fit. Um, and
you know what's weird? I noticed this at
YC as a YC partner.
Someone that gets into YC with an idea
that's just a total fail like
immediately is actually a huge advantage
than someone that has like a little bit
of traction. Isn't that weird? Like a
total fail. The founders can declare
bankruptcy on the idea immediately and
just work on other stuff with no regrets
and no like second guessing. Oh, should
I pivot? You know, they're like, "Wow,
that was really bad." [laughter] And
having that freedom to immediately throw
off the old idea and work on a new one
is actually a weird advantage. Isn't
that counterintuitive? And so you just
want to really watch out for a little
bit of traction because I've seen that
be a trap that have capture a lot of
really talented people for long periods
of time. Um,
and then let's just talk about the
anecdotes. Um, so anecdotes about, you
know, stories of people that just kept
doing what they were doing and it didn't
work and then 5 years later, you know,
it was great. I think those are cool and
they're inspirational and I like them
and I they're all true. You know,
they're anecdotes, but it's kind of like
anecdotes about people that, you know,
played the lottery every day for like 5
years and then they won the lottery and
now they're like really happy and, you
know, that's super cool, but that is not
actionable for you, right? There's
nothing you can do with this anecdote
about someone that like just kept
believing strong enough. Um, like
I would much rather give people advice
to play the statistics of this and to
take accountability for like their own
actions in the world than just like hope
and dream that you might be one of the
anecdotes too. Um, and so if you decide
to pivot or don't decide to pivot, just
remember you decide. It's your life and
if it works out good or bad, that's on
you. And so often I get founders that
want to push this decision on me as a YC
partner or other authority figures about
is this idea working or not? When should
I know when to give up? And ultimately
all we can do is give you guidance. But
this is exactly in the class of problems
that is on the founder and never
something you should look to an
authority figure to tell you how to
decide. Product market fit. I'm sure you
know we're talking about this a lot.
It's been discussed a lot in startup
school and it's because it is so
important. Most people will never get
it. Probably most people watching this
don't have it even if they think they
do. Um, and you know you have it when
growth is not your biggest problem. It's
other stuff. And one good reason to
pivot is you just get more shots on goal
to try to get this elusive thing, right?
Like if you made something and you
launched it and it's like not really
working. Um, a dang good reason to pivot
is you get another roll of the dice. you
get another shot. And so I've just seen
people that use these opportunities
really well, it's much easier to be
lucky when you get like half a dozen
shots on goal than one, right? And so
just if we're just playing the
statistics of how do I get product
market fit, taking several high quality
shots, notice I say high quality, you
can't just constantly pivot through
stuff and other launch it. But if you do
a full awesome product iteration of
making something, completing it,
shipping it, giving it to people,
following all the advice you're looking
here, and you can give yourself multiple
of those shots, um, I would argue you
are creating luck for yourself, and the
odds that you actually hit something
that works are much higher than someone
that only ever takes one shot.
Okay, let's talk about how to find a
better idea. Um, here's the advice that
I give people during the batch when they
are looking for an idea to pivot to. Um,
find something that you're more excited
about and that makes you more optimistic
about the world and more just generally
more excited to wake up in the morning
and work on the thing. Um, and not less
excited. And there's a correlary here
and this I think is counterintuitive.
Often choosing what is perceived as a
harder idea
is more uh is is good. And so I see a
lot of people where they're like working
on some like ad network ad tech thing to
like affiliate something ad targeting. I
don't know those like never work and
it's because they're not inspirational
and no one cares. And so when you see
people go from that into something
that's really really exciting, right?
like, "Oh, I want to help small business
owners do X or I had a company in this
last batch um and they did uh they
started with um this ad tech thing that
they were all very bored with and they
pivoted to Robin Hood for India and the
moment they pivoted to that they the
founders they were like they lit up and
every conversation I had with them they
were like so excited about their idea
and it was contagious talking to them.
Um, and it was almost like a different
like the amount of change. It was the
same founders, but what changed is they
found an idea that was real that they
were excited about and not just some
like boring ad tech crap. No one cares
about that stuff. Okay. So, if you're
doing something that seems like a good
startup idea because you read in
Techrunch, people raise money for it,
but it's not inspiring to you and you're
like, man, this is pretty lame. Um, you
probably want to find something that's
more exciting to you. Another thing to
do on a finding a better idea is make an
honest assessment of what you're good
and bad at. This is hard, but you want
to be really self-aware of what you're
good and bad at and play to those
strengths. And another thing here for
finding a good idea is, especially if
it's a pivot, find something that you
can very quickly build and validate and
not something that takes like a year or
two of R&D, right? Often like if you
pivot from one thing that's impossible
to ship into another thing that's
impossible to ship, not good. Ideally,
you find something that's way easier to
ship like really fast. Highly
recommended. Quick note here, caveat.
[clears throat]
It's totally okay to work an idea where
you're not going to raise venture
capital. All good. Most businesses in
the world don't require venture capital.
And so all of your if what you're doing
is consuming lots of content on how to
start a company like this and it's all
kind of like venture capital focused
stuff um and you're not going to do
something that raises venture capital,
you can kind of get blown off course
idea-wise. And so, um, just be
self-aware about this and
realize that if you do want to raise
venture capital,
the idea does matter a lot. And there's
a constant like recurring theme I see is
people that are trying to raise money
for something that is definitely not
venture capital fundable and they get
really frustrated. Everyone gets
frustrated with that. It just it doesn't
make sense for all businesses. And so
just be self-aware of this when you're
choosing an idea of like is this
something that at least hypothetically
is VC fundable. Just to give you some
rule of thumb what does that mean? Um I
don't think there's a guidebook for what
venture scale means but here's some
rules of thumb. Can I imagine this
business generating hundreds of millions
or billions in net revenue per year?
That sounds venture capital funable. Um
can I imagine the revenue growth to get
to those numbers to happen in like less
than 10 years or 5 years? Like can this
happen really fast? Um, can I imagine
this thing that I'm doing is a publicly
traded company someday? Can I picture
it? Can I visualize it? Um, Kevin's
first lecture talks about this, but
these are all things like if you just
can't see any of these, that's not a
great sign. And other key properties is
usually technology is a key component.
And usually the founders build the
technology, at least in the early days,
for something to be VC fundable. Um, you
want to see really high margins, not for
everything, but again, just a rule of
thumb. Software margins, you know, 80%
gross margins, 70% gross margins. Really
high margins is some of you would want
to see. And then, um, just it's funny
like I think a lot of people learn about
fundraising from Shark Tank. And I don't
think a lot of that stuff is venture
fundable, just in case you were
wondering. Um, it's it's fundable for
people that want to put product stuff
together, but I don't know if mo, you
know, I think you'd have a hard time
raising money from venture capitals for
the majority of that stuff. But hey,
like I said earlier, it's your call.
It's your it's your dream. So figure it
out. When's the best time to pivot? As
soon as these things happen, you've
launched and trying to get users for
weeks or months and you feel hopeless.
It feels hopeless. You should probably
pivot when the idea is impossible to get
started with. Like cool, once we raise
$100 million, then we will build a
prototype. You should definitely pivot
if you're one of those people because
unless you have $100 million, you are in
a chicken and egg unsolvable issue. Um,
and here's another one. You know, in
your heart it's not going to work. A lot
of founders know secretly that their
thing isn't working, but they want to
keep up this front to everyone in the
world that it is working and they think
they can fool people into funding them
or working with them. If you can't
convince yourself and you know this
isn't really working, man, is that a
good time to pivot, right? Like, you
know more than anyone else about your
business. So, you got to listen to
yourself and it's sometimes not stuff
you want to hear from yourself. Um,
okay. Let's talk about other pivoting
stuff. If you pivot over and over and
over again, it causes whiplash. Whiplash
is very bad because it causes founders
to give up and not want to work on this
anymore. And that actually kills the
company. Weirdly, it's more deadly to
your company to get whiplash and get sad
than to work on a bad idea. Because if
you're having fun working on a bad idea,
you won't give up. And then conceivably,
you can maybe make it work. If you get
really sad and hate your life while
you're working on your startup, you will
definitely not succeed. and it's because
you will give up. And so this is weird.
Like it's kind of better to work on an
idea that's not the best one if you're
really having fun. Um, and then you just
want to be in a happy medium. Some
founders pivot way too much and they'll
probably watch this lecture and then
like pivot once a day for six weeks.
Don't do that. And some people just work
on the same idea for five years and it's
not working and they just are really
obset about it. Just find the happy
medium like everything else in life. Um,
another thing is it's really hard to
have employees and be pivoting. So don't
do it. It just makes it slower and it
makes them really sad. And so trying to
scale up like a team and taking all the
advice here about how to scale a team
while you don't even know what your idea
is or you think you're going to change
your idea, definitely not best
practices. Um it only slows you down. I
would only add people to the team after
you know your idea is working and you
have confidence. Otherwise, it's just
all downside. Um okay, let's go to a
different thing here. I made this up for
this lecture and I came up with a
subjective notion of a quality score
just to give you a few criteria to
evaluate an idea. Okay? And so what I
did is there's you know four key things
that I think you could use to evaluate
the quality of an idea and you could
give them a 1 to 10 and you average
those together to give an overall
quality score. Okay. So let me just go
into detail on these. How big of an idea
it seems to be and again this is the
stuff I talked about earlier. Is this an
obvious publicly traded company? Like,
um, I don't know, Tesla. Hey, it's a new
car company. There's lots of publicly
traded car companies. That seems pretty
big. A new bank. There's lots of banks
that are publicly traded. That seems
pretty big. Uh, the opposite end of the
spectrum is like, um, I don't know, a
franch a subway. I'm going to buy a
Subway franchise, you know. Um, you
know, that's the that's the other end of
the spectrum or like, oh, I'm going to
import some stuff and sell it on eBay.
You know, probably a little little less
obvious how that's big. Um, the second
one, founder market fit is really really
key. So, again, a 10 out of 10 would be,
hey, I was on the self-driving car team
when I was in undergrad and then I
worked on self-driving cars my whole
career and so now I'm going to do a
self-driving car startup. Yeah, that's a
10 out of 10. A zero out of 10 is like,
I'm going to do some kind of advanced AI
startup and I don't know how to program.
That's a zero out of 10 right there.
don't recommend that. How easy is it to
get started on the idea is actually I
think undersold. I don't know if people
realize this is actually really key. Um
is ideas that are easy to start highly
recommended and there's so many really
good ideas out there that never work
because the founders can't figure out
how to get started and then someone in
the future does the same idea and has a
much better way to get started and then
they win and then people get bitter
because they're like I had that idea.
Um, so I would argue getting find an
idea that's easy to get started with um
is just as important as the idea itself.
And finally, early market feedback from
customers. This just means does do
people just want it immediately in a
sales straightforward um or is it just
impossible?
So let me give you some examples of
companies that I worked with and advised
at YC that you may or may not have heard
of. BS is one. um they were in YC17 and
they were I funded them to do a
different idea um and talked to them a
lot during their pivot and they pivoted
during the batch and they got product
market fit pretty quickly and they have
now raised hundreds of millions and are
worth billions in two years. So it's
like one of those rare outlier stories.
I'm not saying this is common, but holy
cow, I got a front row seat to watching
kind of the most epic pivot of all time.
I think maybe there's other ones, but I
was like, "Wow, that really worked." So,
let's talk about the before and after.
Here was what they started with. They
had this idea for a new VR hardware
headset that you would use to do work or
something. Um, and so if you Here's the
scores I just put in, you know, and I
put these in. Now, these I didn't do
these at the time, but how big does it
seem? Yeah, it seems like medium big
like VR headsets. I don't there's no
publicly traded ones, but that seems
like the future, right? Um, Founder
Market Fit, uh, I gave a one out of 10.
These guys knew nothing about hardware
or optics or any of the things
associated. They were just fintech
software folks. So they had literally no
idea what they were doing and they were
very upfront about that. Um how easy it
was to get started. That's only a two.
And the reason is they had to hire
hardware people to build a prototype.
Not a good sign. They needed millions of
dollars to build a prototype. Not a good
sign. And it would take like years and
years and years of manufacturing. So
this was pretty bad. Um and then finally
early market feedback. They went and
talked to people and they're like, "Do
you want to use this?" and no one wanted
to use it. So this was bad.
Okay. So overall score two and a half
out of 10. Okay. Post pivot credit card
for startups that seemed pretty big.
There's tons of publicly traded comps of
like fintech companies. You know again
even in startup land there's there's
Square Stripe. I mean there's lots of
examples of that. So I would give that a
10 out of 10. I did at the time founder
market f 10 out of 10. Uh I I the reason
is they had started a fintech company
earlier in Brazil and it was successful
and they sold it for like 20 or $30
million. So they knew exactly what they
were doing and they could write all the
code themselves and they could ship it
themselves and they had all these
existing relationships. Man is that such
a better fit. Um how easy it was to get
started. I'm only giving this a three
out of 10 cuz they actually it's hard to
launch a new credit card product. This
is one where if you ar don't have
founder market fit, I would not
necessarily try this at home. Um there
was something about the founder market
fit that made it easy. And then finally
the early market feedback I'm giving
eight out of 10. And it's because in the
batch they were like hey do you have a
credit card? Do you want to be a
customer? And people were like yes. And
that was a whole sales process. Like I
witnessed it multiple times. So if if
that's your sales process
good [laughter] it's like a threeinut
sales process and people say yes. That
is good. Let's talk about retool.
They're a winner 17 and they're a really
good SAS company and honestly everyone
should check it out and maybe use it.
It's a tool to build internal tools.
It's awesome. Um I'm encouraging all the
YC startups to use this to build
internal management pages. It's it's
actually like a really great product. So
um that's what retool is. You should
look at it. Pre- pivot was Vinmo for the
UK. Um how big it seems seems pretty
big. Like Vinmo's big. Um found a market
fit three out of 10. They didn't really
know anything about fintech, but they
managed to get a launch, so there was
something there. How easy it was to get
started, I'm giving that a 7 out of 10.
It's because they already launched. They
had already had a bunch of users then,
so that was pretty impressive. And you
know, early market feedback though was
only three out of 10. And the reason is
no one wanted to pay and they were
losing money on every transaction. So
there's all these reasons this wasn't
really working. And so they decided to
pivot. Even though this is an example of
the insidious
sort of traction, right? they had enough
traction that it was like hard to decide
to give up on this um because they had
users and it was like kind of working.
Um so that was a tricky one. Um anyway,
retool post pivot is the no code
internal tools built builder. I think it
seems like a 10 out of 10 because 80% of
all software built is for internal
consumption not external consumption
like at big companies and so that seems
like a big market to me. Founder market
fit 10 out of 10. Uh one of the founders
had made something like this. It is
college internship and so he had a very
good idea of what the product should be.
um and had relevant to it. Um it was
easy to get started. They built it in
two weeks and got their first customers.
Great. And early market feedback, I only
given a five out of 10. People were
interested in it, but they weren't sure
they wanted to trust some new startup to
this thing. So it this one did not fly
off the proverbial shelves. They managed
to get some users, but it was not
immediate obvious product market fit.
They had to build it out a bit. So that
was a great pivot. Next, we got Magic.
They were in winter 15. Um they pivoted
during the batch. And what's great about
them is they built a profitable and
sustainable company. Yay. I wish we all
could do that, right? Um, how did they
do it? They started off with this idea
for a blood pressure coach where there
was an app and you enter your blood
pressure and it would tell you how to
lower your blood pressure. Um, uh,
didn't seem like a huge idea. Uh, two
out of 10. Find a market fit. They
didn't know anything about health
whatsoever or much along those lines.
So, that's probably just a two out of
10. How easy was he to get started?
Eight out of 10 because they built the
app really quickly and they got users
really quickly and they followed all the
advice. Good for them. And then the
early market feedback was like not good.
Everyone was really polite and no one
used the dang thing. Like their usage
was just horrible. So this one was again
was kind of obvious they should pivot.
They realized it on their own pretty
quickly. And then they built a bunch of
prototypes. They actually built the
magic prototype in a weekend. No joke.
This is actually true. Uh not an
exaggeration. And they put it on
HackerNews and it went to number one and
got like 2,000 up votes and it blew up
overnight. I don't know if anyone
remembers this thing, but it went like
crazy viral. Um and they got all this
press. like it was the most it was an
example of a shots on goal thing I was
talking about earlier where they didn't
know like they they had like five ideas
and there's no way I would have known
and they would have known that this
would be the thing that would capture
the world's imagination but it did um
and so not obvious founder market fit on
this one either but it was very easy to
get started it got really good early
market feedback and it seems pretty big
um so that was great it also in
inadvertently uh inspired tons and tons
of clones so I would argue that anyone
that's doing chatbot stuff. It's sort of
like a direct descendant about when this
thing blew up and everyone was like,
"Oh, chat bots are the future." Uh, was
sort of like second order effects from
this going so crazy viral and inspiring
so many people. Segment there in YC
Summer 11. Um, they pivoted a bunch of
times including years after the batch.
It took them a really long time to get
it going. They didn't even pivot during
the batch and now they're worth billions
and it's a really good company. Um, it's
a top data infrastructure company. So
prep pivot they had this thing that was
a classroom feedback tool where like you
would give it to students in a classroom
and they could say if it was if they
were lost or not I think was what the
feature was. Um so if you were confused
you would like push a button and it
would tell the professor okay didn't
seem huge um in my opinion finder market
fit well they were students and they
were young so I would give that like a
five out of 10. They weren't experts on
education but they understood the
audience. um it was easy to get started.
They built it really fast and the early
market feedback was actually decent
where professors liked it and they got a
bunch of schools to adopt this thing. So
their sales were successful but
ultimately this was not you know it took
them on the order of years to discard
this one. Um and yeah this was it's good
that they pivoted because now they're
doing segment again which everyone
should use. Uh it's a data collection
tool. That one did not seem obviously
big. Have you anyone here used segment?
It's this JavaScript thing you put on
your page and it connects to other
tools. It was less obvious how that
would be a publicly traded company at
the time. Um, but the founder market fit
was great because they had built so much
analytics stuff. They were world experts
on analytics already when they built it.
Um, it was easy to get started because
they literally built this thing and open
sourced it and gave away for free and
people begged for them to support it.
Like the market begged for this product
to exist. They didn't think this was the
company. They just had this like thing
on GitHub and so many people were
obsessed with this thing that they
built. They're like, "Well, I guess the
market's telling us we should make this
the company." And they did it. So, that
I would say is uh easy to get started
and really good market feedback. You
know, if the market's begging for
something and that you don't even think
it's good and they have to convince you
it's good, that's a pretty good sign.
Um, and so that was a good pivot. Okay,
[clears throat] in summary, I tried to
give you those examples just to give you
real real life examples of stuff that I
personally worked on just to show like
the before and after and how these
decisions are really made. And so
changing your idea is part of a startup,
the sooner the better. Um, because of
the opportunity cost and the shots on
goal type of stuff. And when you're
considering changing idea, especially
the early stages, it shouldn't feel like
a big deal. You should probably do it
all the time. And following best
practices is recommended. Hopefully I
gave you some good pointers on what
those best practices are, but if you're
really scientific about this, you can
dramatically increase the odds uh that
your startup will work. Great. That's it
for me. Thanks.
[applause]